turning to Ukraine now and Military the
the war in Ukraine just think about that
story yeah you too I can't really do
that so that's just unfortunate um yeah
all right we are going to turn to
Ukraine though uh and the war overseas
Russia says a military withdrawal from
the important southern city of Harrison
is complete an advisor says that
Ukraine's president informing the troops
left behind a quote city of death
Ukraine's forces are wary of potential
ambushes as they Liberate the region but
they do continue to keep pressure on the
retreating Russians and Chris livesay is
in Ukraine for us with a look at the
latest fighting
Russian forces flee the West Bank of the
Napa River once their stronghold now
among the 41 settlements Ukraine has
recaptured in the occupied Harrison
region
these soldiers just a few miles from
Enemy Lines are using drones to hone in
on Russian positions here is Russians
here is he going to the trench they're
now marked men you can see the Russians
over here
that's incoming but the Russians can
also see the ukrainians further back the
artillery takes aim
[Music]
drone images capture the moment of
impact
and just as quickly as they came these
Fighters now exposed must flee the scene
but not the region after nearly nine
months of occupation and atrocities
beyond the southern front it's the
Russians who are finally doing that
Russian forces now leave behind a deadly
trail of landmines and booby traps
Ukrainian civilians have been killed
when they found a landmine hid inside
their washing machine or underneath
their bed so Ukrainian forces are now
proceeding with Extreme Caution for CBS
mornings Chris lives say uman Ukraine